notre invité du jour ses marques tirreni
sans multi de marchiani bonjour vous
êtes chercheur merci d'être à nos côtés
chercheurs pour carnegie europe ancien
ambassadeur par ailleurs de de l'union
européenne notamment en turquie j'espère
que vous entendiez de carmel était en
train de nous détailler me l'écrire ici
j'aimerais d'abord avoir votre sentiment
à vous sur ce qu'il faut attendre ou pas
d'ailleurs de ces de ces pourparlers qui
sont nouveau relancé en terrain turc a
aujourd'hui je dirais que les chances de
progrès sont assez limitées parce que la
turquie
est en position difficile elle est bien
sûr capable de parler des deux côtés
elle a amené dans son propre avion
alegre son urine yen à istanbul tout ça
c'est très bien mais le président turc
je vous ferai remarquer a dit ce matin
dans son petit discours d'ouverture que
il n'était pas en position de médiation
et donc c'est une opération de
facilitation qui bien sûr un beau coup
davantage pour la turquie il ya une
question de prestige d'une part parce
qu'il ya des élections dans 15 mois et
il ya aussi comme on vient de le dire le
commerce le tourisme
et naturellement la perspective de la
reconstruction de l'ukraine après la
guerre qui a aussi un intérêt pour pour
la turquie mais il faut bien voir que la
russie avec les difficultés qu'on lui
connaît pour l'offensive thérèse
changé depuis quelques jours de tactique
qu'elles emploient de nouveaux moyens et
elle opère une dévastation massive
dévastation des habitations civiles de
des bâtiments administratifs des
hôpitaux des écoles et bien sûr aussi de
l'industrie ukrainienne donc ça selon
vous marc pyrénées on a beaucoup
commenté ce redéploiement des russes a
annoncé par communiqué vendredi la
région du don bas serait devenu la
nouvelle priorité alors qu'au début de
cette guerre on parlait de démilitariser
2d nazifié l'ukraine tout entière
certains commentateurs estiment que les
russes sont en difficulté vous si je
vous entends aujourd'hui
même s'ils sont en difficulté sur le
terrain ça ne veut pas dire qu'ils vont
abandonner pour autant et négocier
rapidement en effet il met la pression
maximale sur l'ukraine et tout au long
de la matinée vous avez bien montrer la
dévastation physique et la
démoralisation de la population de
marioupol de nicolay est fait et
d'autres d'autres rient et il ya une
course il ya une course entre une
offensive russe qui ne porte pas les
fruits
escomptés par les moyens habituels c'est
à dire une offensive terrestre avec des
chars mais qui continue à porter ses
fruits si je puis dire à travers une
offensive de missiles de croisière et de
bombardements aériens qui sont effectués
depuis le territoire de la russie donc
contre lesquels ni l'ukraine ni bien sûr
l'otan a fortiori non de moyens de
résister mais en même temps l'ukraine
reçoit de plus en plus d'armements elle
se défend avec vigueur donc il ya une
sorte de course de vitesse et c'est bien
sûr comme d'habitude dans ce genre de
choses à celui qui flanche sera le
premier